[Music]
let's take up one more concept that is
first principles and SRP let's see that
what it is
the first principle structures the
description and create value of the best
suits not all the first principle can be
followed in your testing use first
principle as a long-term Valentina
this suit let's see that what all those
five principles are fast isolated
independent repeatable self while
leading float angry so your test
whatever the tests you are writing it
should be fast enough so that's why we
always discussed that void use of thread
Bosley what explicit way to put implicit
weight as you may be spending and not of
extra time so better avoid this isolated
independent minimize dependency between
this as far as possible
so there shouldn't be dependent along
that this cases should not be dependent
on each other because if one fails it
may be possible the other one will not
run in that case okay you can make your
case is dependent on each other as much
as possible and also in your test Keys
in short at least in verification of
course we will be having that
verification because that's a
requirement repeatable configured tests
so not relearning the test always give
consistent episode we have to keep now
our test case is greatly in different
different methods so that in even if we
rerun it won't impact the results and of
course it will not impact and it
actually does not apply to this as well
validating while writing the test you
should automate patient as automation
suits run without human intervention
don't assume any human intervention so
always whenever you are creating
your frameworks or test scripts don't
think that you will be providing some
input to it never ever give any input to
the your test cases to your automation
pack make it in such a way but it can be
freely or it can be run in your absence
as well so what you will do you will
schedule it at 3:00 a.m. in the night
and it will run and we'll give you the
results not to make your test in such a
way not that that it requires your input
like verification here we are saying you
should automate verification you know so
when you are opening up a website you
should verify whether it has actually
opened or not that is actually opening
that particular URL or going to that URL
or it is going to some other different
model need to verify all these things
probably a thorough timely this is
applicable to any test this test should
be through in the terms of coverage so
when I say in the terms of coverage you
know raised what happens in your test
cases in unit testing we write code in
selenium also the write code and in code
we write some variables we create some
methods some extra methods some extra
line of code as well if we write an
extra line of cool that means the
program will print sponsor program will
get executed execution time we Filipino
at it if you are adding some more things
if you are using object which are not
being used anywhere cooperating objects
are not so we are now creating variable
which are not being used in English of
course Java while executing tower will
take care of them and will see them but
it will go through through those steps
which is of no use acted in your steps
so here in terms of coverage what it
means is you should get the code
coverage that you have written hundred
percent of your blog you have written
your complete code but actually how much
percent is being used 50% 60% 70% so
there are some code coverage tools which
you can use and can see that actually
how much food is being
used when you write your script it may
be possible that the 50% of the script
is only useful 20% is you know it's
completely not is of no use so when you
get the coverage code coverage report
you can see that which one is of no use
and you can remove those extra lines
that's a benefit of poor coverage and it
is applicable of unit tests it is
applicable in selenium as well a very
very very less people hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simple
learn YouTube channel and click here to
watch similar videos turner up and get
certified click here